♪ ♪ ♪
- Les skieurs sont de retour
sur les pentes. Ce n'est pas
encore la foule, mais cet hiver,
ils seront nombreux.
- Oui, c'est la première!
- C'est quoi l'état d'esprit?
- Ah, et que j'avais hâte
de commencer, là!
- On est retombés à notre sport
qu'on avait v'là 30 ans. On a
rembarqué dans le ski alpin.
Première journée aujourd'hui,
puis là, on s'en va voir
de quoi qu'on parle!
- (Rires)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le ski alpin connaît
un nouvel essor depuis
quelques années et la COVID
semble avoir accéléré
cette tendance.
- D'en faire plus, de
profiter de la vie plus,
de pas rester à la maison
tout le temps, surtout
retraités, faut s'occuper.
- On est plus libre, hein,
avec le billet de saison.
T'arrives, puis, tu mets
tes bottes, t'embarques sur
la pente direct.
- Bon an mal an, 300 000 skieurs
achètent un billet de saison
dans l'une des 74 stations
de ski du Québec.
Leur association prévoit
cette année une hausse
de 10 à 20 % des abonnements.
SIMON PAGÉ, directeur,
Sommet Saint-Sauveur
- Tous les abonnements
qu'on avait mis en vente
sont complets. Il est plus
possible présentement de
s'acheter un abonnement.
Même chose au niveau
des programmes d'école
de glisse, là, dès
la mi-octobre, l'ensemble
des programmes affichaient
complets.
- Grosse saison en vue
au Mont St-Bruno,
la station la plus rapprochée
de Montréal.
STÉPHANIE GRENIER, dir. ventes,
market., exp., Ski St-Bruno
- Les abonnementvendusvendusvens
et au printemps et à l'automne,
on en a environ 50 % que
c'est des nouvelles personnes
qui étaient jamais venues
à la montagne, donc, pour nous,
c'est un grand succès.
- Ski St-Bruno, qui est
la plus importante école
de ski alpin au Canada,
a décidé, pour la première fois,
de ne plus offrir de cours
les après-midi de fins de
semaine, question de faire
plus de place aux skieurs
d'un jour.
- On va pas obliger de réserver,
mais on va conseiller fortement.
Donc, dans le fond, nous,
si on voit, surtout les soirs,
si on voit que l'achalandage
est assez élevé, évidemment,
on va réduire le nombre
de billets. Donc, on va
contrôler au niveau des soirées.
- Au niveau des billets
journaliers, il y en a
qui sont en vente, les gens,
c'est très important, doivent
réserver à l'avance,
vraiment acheter à l'avance
pour s'assurer des billets
disponibles. On a pris
la décision pour l'instant
de continuer à limiter
les billets. On va s'assurer
d'une belle expérience
en station.
- Au Mont-Tremblant,
où la surface
est beaucoup plus grande,
on ne compte pas limiter
les entrées cet hiver.
Même chose à Bromont en Estrie.
Mais une majorité de stations
pourraient bien le faire,
surtout pendant les vacances.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Parce que la pandémie
n'est pas encore finie.
D'ailleurs, le passeport
vaccinal est obligatoire
partout cet hiver. Chaque skieur
sera contrôlé à l'entrée.
- Les mesures sont beaucoup
des recommandations, donc,
au niveau des télésièges,
les gens, le port du couvre-
visage est recommandé, mais
il n'y a plus de restrictions
en tant que tel à l'extérieur.
Ce qui est positif, c'est
le fait que l'ensemble
des services à la clientèle
peuvent être ouverts.
- On est contents
des assouplissement,
bien entendu, parce qu'on
peut maintenant rentrer
dans le chalet, on peut
apporter nos choses.
- Ça fait du bien, mais, moi,
je préfère encore les mesures
d'un mètre, et non d'être
collés dans les chaises.
Je me colle pas sur quelqu'un
que je connais pas.
- La COVID a changé les
habitudes et certaines
pourraient rester, comme
celle de réserver en ligne
avant d'aller skier.
Les stations espèrent que
les Québécois s'y habitueront,
question de mieux prévoir
leur achalandage.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Saint-Sauveur.
- Pascal, on a besoin de vos
lumières.
Heureusement qu'on fait de la
nage, parce que ça pourrait être
plus difficile.
Est-ce que ça va aller en
s'accélérant les épisodes de
pluie?
C'est un bel exemple, demain, je
vais faire du ski, mais je n'y
réponds pas.
- Les conditions hivernales, et
même à l'arrière de cela, ça
sera encore doux.
Si on regarde les quantités de
neige, dans les années 70, on
recevait au-delà de 260 de
neige, et on est rendu à un peu
plus de 200.
On voit qu'à chaque année, c'est
une tendance, il y en a de moins
en moins. Quand on regarde les
Quand on regarde les Noell
verre, dans les années 70,80 %
des nouv aujourd'hui, elles
50 % sont verts.
Les saisons sont plus courts, ça
veut dire que la nage vient plus
tard.
On se rappelle de l'hiver 2007
2008, on a eu des quantités
phénoménales de neige, mais ça
n'a pas duré.
- Les épisodes de pluie en
vont être plus fréquents.
- On se rappelle ce qu'il s'est
passé à Noël l'année dernière,
il avait fait 14° et beaucoup de
pluie à l'argent du Québec.
On voit qu'il y a moins de
neige, de pluie.
C'est à peu près le scénario...
On le voit dans les
statistiques, et on le voit dans
les projections de future.
- Il y a une association qui a
es études. Le ski au
Québec en 2050, vous allez me
dire que c'est loin, mais ce
n'est pas si loin.
Le retard du début de la saison,
de sept à 10 jours.
- On va encore avoir de la
neige, c'est clair, on peut
avoir des tempêtes de neige de
40 cm, mais la saison commence
est plus réduite, compte tenu du
climat qu'on a.
- S'il n'avait pas eu cette
invention, vous allez me dire
que ce n'est pas si compliqué de
faire la nage, ils font de la
nage avec de l'eau, est-ce que
ça vous fascine devant cette
neige artificielle?
- Écoutez, ça fait longtemps que
ça existe.
Ça donne des micros gouttelettes
qui vont congeler.
Ça donne neige, pas une neige
naturelle, mais, non.
Ça ne m'étonne pas qu'il y en
ait de plus en plus.
On a essayé de faire cela, on ne
fait des tentatives, mais le
problème, dans certains cas,
c'est difficile.
La nature c'est complexe.
En pulvérisant de l'eau à basse
température, on peut former une
neige plus compacte, mais pas
poudreuses comme on retrouve au
naturel.
- Un mot sur le ski de fond.
- C'est plus problématique.
- Vous dîtes quand même qu'on ne
plusieurs années devant nous.
Il y aura de la neige naturelle
janvier, février, mars.
- Je me rappelle quand j'étais
jeune, dans les années 70, dans
les années 60 aussi, on avait 30
cm et plus à Noël.
Et là, on cherche la neige à
Noël.
Si on regarde ce qui se prépare
la semaine prochaine, c'est
énormément doux, je ne
m'étonnerai pas qu'on atteindre
jeudi prochain...
- le 24 décembre, on marchait
dans la rue en T-shirt.
- 16°.
Le record à Montréal, c'était
18°.
Tout le monde qu'on pourrait se
sauver